and Kelly your daughter's just has
recently had a baby she has yeah Sydney
Sharon Osborne makes a big reveal and
her daughter Kelly is not too happy
about it you are guilty of that yeah
Kelly responded by seemingly shading her
mom on Instagram story writing I am not
ready to share him with the world and if
no one's place but mine to share any
information on my baby this comes after
Sharon confirmed Kelly gave birth on the
British show of the talk and even shared
the little one's name and Kelly your
daughter's just has recently had a baby
she has yeah Sydney there's a lot going
on seems the proud grandma couldn't hold
back her excitement I mean she's even
showing off pics it's always a Canyon
City doing oh just so so great so great
she won't let a picture go out of him oh
really yeah and I'm so proud of her yeah
oh okay but you showed me some pictures
earlier
now this isn't the first family member
to Spill the Beans about Kelly's
pregnancy you have another grandbaby on
the way congratulations Kelly's big and
she's beautiful and I love it six months
congratulations thank you she's having a
boy
yep Kelly's dad Ozzy first revealed she
was pregnant with a baby boy and I'm
like thanks Dad he's told everyone the
gender of my baby before I ever got the
chance to and I'm just like oh Dad come
on like come on but I will say every
single day he he does this little song
in this little dance about how excited
he is and he is so excited that it's a
boy it's the first from out of me and my
brother it's the first boy
Kelly announced she was expecting her
first kiddo with boyfriend Sid Wilson
back in May on Instagram I know that I
have been very quiet these past few
months so I thought I would share with
you all as to why I'm over the moon to
announce that I am going to be a mama to
say that I am happy does not quite cut
it I am ecstatic and you guys have been
buddies for like 20 some odd years at
what point did it become romantic like
when did you know it was weird it just
kind of
like we'd always check in with each
other a couple times a year we see each
other at different events and
I mean I I was like 13 or 14 when I
first met him then suddenly about a year
ago it just changed I can't explain it
yeah congrats to the new parents
[Music]